Oh big congrats being honored here
tonight by the way with your co-star
Mark Ruffalo from the rumor has it Days
2003 oh my god congratulations and you
got your girls here tonight
Courtney and Lisa right how does it feel
to have their support from the audience
oh that's it's incredible that it's like
having your family standing right behind
you because these things are a little
nerve-wracking
do you get nervous oh god I forgot my
beta blocker at home and literally just
went through you have no idea many
levels of panic trying to figure out a
way to get it to me Jill you look like
Debra Messing all the time I will take
that as a big compliment it is well
there's someone gonna get you that beta
block you one last question last time I
saw you at the variety event you said
look you guys have just done the friends
lunch you got to find the right project
I know Matthew and Courtney got lunch
together today we don't get invited to
that I mean what could the right project
be if it's not a friends reboot what do
you guys want to do together
oh god that's there's there's a lot of
different ideas but who knows
[Music]
you